so you've done work on sort of looking
for moral clarity how can we go about
searching for that mm-hmm it's funny
because we had a in the discussion on
evil a little while ago various people
remarked that evil sells better and
creates more interest than goodness and
that of course is has been my own
experience I did write a book that I
spent 10 years writing called evil and
modern thought I'm still proud of that
book the point was to move philosophy
away from questions about knowledge and
realism and skepticism and how can we
ever know anything and is this a hand or
is this a cup which is the way that many
people in university are introduced to
philosophy my argument is if you
actually look at the old text and
confined myself to Western philosophy
because that's what I know best what you
see actually is that people are asking a
different question namely how can I find
meaning in my life and live it well in
the face of inexplicable and unjust
suffering and evil and having written
that book I felt the strong need to do
something else I don't think it's
healthy to write you know just been was
life focused on evil I think if we focus
on evil it's actually because some piece
of us wants to find well I think we
actually do have moral ideas and we'd
like to realize them so how do you get
moral clarity here's how you don't get
it I don't think philosophy goes very
far by trucking in definitions
I think people waste a lot of time
trying to give general answers and
general definitions of the
like good and evil and moral concepts I
think what we need is to get good about
describing very particular situations
and asking questions about them and
that's how we come to get clearer what I
think is really interesting in this
particular historical moment is the
phenomenon of embarrassment
which is an embarrassing thing where it
should be an embarrassing thing but I
think we live in a culture which has
made as comfortable with irony and
uncomfortable with ideals and I mean you
look at it in television and I cannot
deny the lore for myself of series like
The Sopranos or the house of cards
they're addictive they're complicated
they're incredibly well done there's no
question about it but there's a formula
at the moment not that I spend my life
watching all the bloody series there are
to watch I can't you get too involved
and then you can't do anything else but
of the ones that I've launched the
formula is you take somebody who's
actually doing something really awful
and fairly early on you know murder
usually comes up and then it turns out
of course that this person is not a
monster in the way that people like to
say think of Nazis as monsters they
weren't monsters either we can talk
about that if you like separately but
they turn out to be complicated
characters Tony Soprano has his ducks
Frank Underwood a each of them have
their marriages and they may love their
wives even if they betray them in
various complicated ways and they're all
well done enough to pull you in very
strongly but what's missing in those
series is a hero or a heroine what's
missing is someone who is really there
simply because they want
do good they want to leave some good in
the world and I mean if you had those
kinds of shows obviously you don't want
to have stick figures either you would
want to have people who had flaws I'm
not talking about superheroes I mean we
do have superheroes films about
superheroes make lots of money but we
know that their fantasy thus most of the
stories about reality tend to focus on
the evildoers and I think that has had
had the consequence of making us cynical
making us limiting the space of
possibility I mean let's face it we're
all more affected by art and I do count
these series as serious art we're more
affected by that than by abstract
principles okay
the space of possibility is peopled by
characters either real or or fictional
and the less we see of people actually
aspiring to fulfill moral ideals of
justice and you know making some
contribution to leaving the world
slightly better than you found it the
less it seems real the more it seems
like a fairy tale yes that's what I
believed when I was a child I myself
have experienced very often first of all
my I like my book on evil I'm proud of
it but that's the one that has been
translated into most languages sold the
most copies the book on moral clarity
know it okay it's still in print it's in
a couple of different languages but it
doesn't get the kind of attention and I
don't think it's because it's a worse
book we were talking in the other
session about other examples of that
kind of a phenomenon but
people will often accuse me when I talk
about moral clarity of being naive when
I talk about idealism and you know in
those situations I'll have to say wait a
second you know I actually know a lot
about evil and not I'm not suggesting
first of all that all we need to that
people are full of ideals and secondly
that all you need to do to realize an
ideal is to have one
I don't but what I am saying is that
phrases that one hears both in politics
and an ordinary life Oh
be realistic be more realistic is a way
of saying decrease your expectations of
the world decrease your expectations of
what you can do and of what you will get
back to the world get back from the
world but the world can give you that I
hope that's the beginning of an answer
to your question so does that mean that
you would say that we should have more
ideals because do you think there exists
small I D --is ideals out there in the
world that are set for everyone for us
to just yeah actually I do and you know
as soon as you make a statement like
that you have somebody coming and
suggesting a strawman version of it well
do you mean like they're up in plato's
heaven and you know somebody can be
mapped to them and and said of course
not you know but if you look cross
culturally as a matter of fact there's a
great deal more agreement than we think
there is there a couple of exceptions
I mean questions about status of women
differ more in different cultures but if
you talk about basic questions of
justice basic questions of fairness
basic questions about honesty cheating
theft it turns out that once you go
from this very abstract point back to
specific cases but actually you do get a
huge amount of cross-cultural agreement
most people do want you know good things
to happen to people who do good things
and bad things to happen or at least you
know the people who behave horrendously
you don't want them to be rewarded for
it
and there's general agreement across the
board yes so why then this gap why this
embarrassment for ideals why's it taking
us with why we still attracted to evil
or evil still exists
well I actually think that part of the
fascination of really horrible cases of
you know murderers for the share
sadistic pleasure of it things like that
I I actually think that takes us away
from the main forces of evil which as
Hana aren't recognized are basically but
now okay
people being lazy people focusing on
very short-term self-interested goals
she wrote a book called Eichmann in
Jerusalem I I think in many ways it's
mourning this important moral texts of
the 20th century although she was wrong
about the person out of Iceland for
reason she could not have known because
information came out after her death her
argument is the reason iseman could be
in charge of the mass murder of six
million Jews is that he was simply
thoughtless he didn't know what he was
doing okay
following orders you want to get ahead
this sort of ordinary things that all of
us do in our lives turns out that
happens to be wrong he knew exactly what
he was doing but that doesn't matter the
Nazis could not have have succeeded had
there not been millions of people
who exactly followed the script that
aren't his that aren't described let's
take what I think is probably the the
greatest evil hanging over our heads
right now which is the climate
catastrophe no one planned that no one
wanted it you know it was all a matter
of very small lazy steps some of which
people even thought were innovations and
would make keep his lives better and no
one thought about the consequences of
what was happening although I mean
what's interesting is I suppose in that
case Exxon and the other oil companies
who actually didn't have these studies
30 years ago didn't know exactly what
was going on and my question there has
always been you know do their children
and grandchildren and some of the must
and you can't you I mean there can't be
enough mountains in the world
to buy your family you know a little
island where where they're going to be
alright I mean we are globalized the
effects will affect everyone but it's
much easier to think about and that's
not the only case of Idul that that I
think is a is a banal case of evil but
it's it's a good one to take and I think
rather than focusing on that because
it's so overwhelming I think we'd much
rather look at you know what are their
names Jeffrey Dahmer or you know
cannibals and people who do really
sensationalist crimes and say okay
that's evil now I know what evil is and
you
go home and take a break and look at
another series with it which is going to
show me about the lives of some other
really interesting figure who's actually
fundamentally evil it's hypnotic I may
equip I confess I can get into these
things I can binge watch as well as the
next person and I feel shitty afterwards
I feel you know like I do that I mean
those were great doughnuts over there
but you know if I ate too many of them
I'd really feel quite sick and I think
that's that's but again I think that's a
big part of our fascination I had a
debate just now as Terry Eagleton who
who did not want to he wants to stick to
the notion of evil as rooted in she you
know only in what human beings do with
intention and I understand why someone
want to do that and I've enormous
respect for Eagleton's work but I think
it's a mistake to see you know evil as
this you know Freudian death wish and
and desire for pure nihilism I that
certainly exists but the interesting
thing and I think the vastly greater
number of cases is we will destroy the
earth if I mean so we will commit as a
race the human race the ultimate act of
nihilism but not because we want to and
that seems to be to be the greater
problem
so what would the ramifications first be
then would you say that we shouldn't
punish individuals for acts of evil
well of course we should of course we
should we have laws the laws to punish
individual acts of evil work better than
the laws to punish large systemic acts
of evil and those are the things that we
need to work I'm not suggesting we let
murderers off the book I'm just
suggesting that we increase the scope of
systemic evils and then moving on to
your work you more recent work you've
done about the need to grow up is there
links between your work on searching for
moral clarity and this work or was it a
sort of a fresh take no it's actually
the reason I read that book what penguin
was doing a series and they said you can
do whatever you like we you know we want
people who can write philosophy for a
general audience and I thought about it
for a while and I was doing an interview
for philosophy magazine in Germany and
the editor had actually read everything
I wrote up to the time and he said you
know I think the thing that links all
your work is the theme of growing up and
I said gosh you're right what you know
I'll write something about that I'll
focus on that that book was intended to
do a number of things one was to
undermine the myth that the best time of
one's life is the time between about 18
and 28 which is a myth
it's empirically wrong I hope you're
enjoying your lives right now I do
sometimes meet people in their twenties
who do and that's great most people I
know once they're out of them would
never choose to repeat them again
they're terribly difficult times of our
lives we're trying to figure out who we
are what we can do what we want
doing all of that and added to that
comes the voice of people in their 40s
and 50s and 60s who say you know this is
the best time of your life enjoy it now
and then you think oh my god not only am
i miserable about you know my love story
or figuring out what job I want but this
is the best time of my life and I'm not
enjoying it you know and they've done
social psychologists have done studies
there's a so-called new curve that
people start getting they get unhappier
and unhappier up to a point and then it
goes up again and it's different at a
rate for different in different cultures
but the one thing that we know
empirically is this is not the happiest
time of one's life so why are we being
sold this myth once again we're being
told be realistic which means accept the
world as it is the world is extremely
limited your choices within it are going
to be more limited still and you'd
better you know face up to it
you'd better resigned and you know we're
resigning means buying into a culture
that equates growth with having more
stuff I mean both for the economy but
also for you know people as individuals
and the goal in that book was to try to
provide a view of growing up which I see
is rooted incant
the most important difference that Kant
drew actually it wasn't just con-com
there's a way in which he took it from
David Hume David Hume said there if
there's a complete difference between
the is and the odd so statements about
what is
are completely different from statements
about what ought to be now what Hume
concluded from that is basically there
is no ought all right because it has no
basis in empirical facts all right it's
just you know comes from Eden put in
those terms but you can call wish
thinking or somebody's trying to assert
their power over you or something like
that and what Khan did was to say yeah
these are two completely different
things and they both have force and they
both have a claim on us and my argument
in that little book is being grown up
involves keeping one eye on the way the
world is and one eye on the way the
world ought to be and not confusing the
two but not giving up on either one so
yeah it is connected with some property
and then you can you identify who
creates them in is it sort of a
capitalist myth or a flea woods
me know so much older than that actually
I mean well look it's interesting
because it's it's very Western and as I
said in starting my knowledge of other
cultural philosophical traditions is
small but I've read enough anthropology
and seen enough of the world to know
that traditionally and still in other
cultures that are not European it's
quite different they're not as child
focused you know growing up his is
something to aspire to and the really
interesting thing is no child wants to
stay a child you know it's children want
to grow up because they create they
equate being adult with being able to
create things having freedom being
autonomous making choices so how is it
created look it's also partly self
created I mean it's it's I
wouldn't say like many important
ideologies that you know wicked people
sat around in a back room and and said
this is how we're going to screw people
over no ideology gets created that way
and what I find so interesting is that
it's self-supporting that it's a myth
that people buy into themselves it was
really funny when I was writing that
book you know if you're a writer and you
see friends you haven't seen in a while
probably the first thing they'll ask you
is so what are you working on these days
and in three different cases the
reaction when I said I'm writing a book
called why grow up
he said ooh Susan what an awful subject
and one of them said to me my hero was
always Peter Pan well the funny thing is
that all three of these grown-ups
they're quite different there's also
three different countries but all of
them fulfill my ideals of being a
grown-up they're all I guess now in
their early 70s they're all working
incredibly actively in their chosen okay
so once an artist - I guess
intellectuals they're all politically
active one of them you know literally
physically outlines they're all
multilingual they're all I mean none of
them has not only has none of them
stopped being in the world they continue
to learn and they continue to give back
to the world and that sense of being
absolutely alive is what those people
equated with being childlike oh I'm
childlike no no now you're a really
successful grown-up although one of them
is completely unsuccessful in
conventional terms that says the other
two are rather successful
but so it's a self-perpetuating ideology
and I'm doing what I can to work against
it and from your own experience than if
your twenties when the most happiest
times of your life would you say there
is a time in which this ideal of youth
is fulfilled well so far I won't say my
life has only gotten better because
they've been rough spots but I feel and
I know this is something when you if you
talk to people a lot of things that you
worry about in your 20s you don't worry
about anymore you know that you can make
mistakes and still pick yourself up from
them you know that you really die of a
broken heart you know that you can have
surprises you know still that will send
your life in in quite unexpected
directions you know that you can take up
new jobs or or serious activities and
you get better at choosing friends
usually you know very quickly my
criterion is always is this someone I
want to be friends with if I change
countries again which I didn't know in
my 20s yeah so my my next book is called
learning from the Germans I think I've
developed a pattern where I try and do
one book on evil if you like and then
turn around and do a book on goodness
just because I think it's healthier this
way this is a book that I began writing
after a young man in Charleston South
Carolina
white supremacists murdered nine black
churchgoers in 2015
and I started thinking about so I I am
an American as I said I was born in the
American South and I grew up surrounded
by the civil rights movement but I have
spent the better part of my adult life
as a Jewish woman in Berlin so the book
starts by saying I as one as a white
girl in the segregated south and I'll
probably die as a Jewish woman in Berlin
and it's a pretty unusual perspective to
have and to think about how cultures
deal with past evils the book is a
departure from for me in several ways
it obviously picks up themes that I've
talked about before but my interest is
not in comparing different evils but
comparing different forms of revenge
Redemption and trying to figure out how
societies can recover from perhaps even
grow from massive acts of evil
so it's booking which I interviewed a
lot of people I I focused on a
comparison between the southern United
States and Germany originally I wanted
to include Britain and and I thought I
would talk about Britain and its
relationship to Ireland because Ireland
is a country that I love and spend a lot
of time in so I know it to some degree -
penguins great disappointment I gave up
on that third of the book because it
simply would have made it so long that
it it you know like this instead of only
like that because it it came to seem to
me that what's terribly important if you
want to learn from these situations is
to focus on once again the particulars
to really go into detail about how
people relate to their parents and how
people are they to their children and
what's learned in the schools and how
people deal with food
sex and ordinary life and how these
gigantic world historical offense events
affect all of that had literature and
and monuments and those kinds of things
so so I can find it mostly to two
different cases although I do talk about
Britain and about other countries and
ways in which I think Europe as a whole
however much Britain as a part of Europe
we don't know historically and
geographically it still kind of is
whatever the brexit errs would like to
say my own view is that brexit might not
have happened had Britain been able to
be more forthcoming about its imperial
past and not be stuck in nostalgia for
it
so is there a specific example of a
lesson that we can learn from Germany
yeah it needs to be first absolutely
head-on and this is not a sign of
weakness it's not you know it doesn't
weaken a country it strengthens the
country and it needs to be faced in all
kinds of ways it needs to be faced in
schools it needs to be faced in the
courts I argue in favor of reparations
but it needs to be faced in art it needs
to be faced in public history so that
means museums that means exhibits that
means monuments and I don't think you
can give a recipe all right but I think
those are broad general areas that every
country needs to deal with that I think
it needs to be fast endured personally I
think people simply need to know what
happened and it's it's quite shocking
how little the you have to be very
careful with what language I'm using it
usually does wind up being white people
but the majority in a culture actually
knows there's a massive amount of
suppression that goes on I mean I I have
met really educated Britain so if you
talk about European imperialism are
surprised that Britain is included in
that which is very bizarre but from my
own case and you know I'm left-wing
America and who
who thought I knew a fair amount about
the civil rights movement but actually
until very recently for almost all white
Americans it's the period between the
Emancipation Proclamation and Rosa Parks
refusing to give up her seat and
Montgomery bus boycott it's just a black
hole people don't know anything about it
and in the past ten years or so they've
been a series of books that have come
out with titles like slavery by another
name and it has become quite clear not
just to specialists or post-colonial
historians or african-americans that
yeah slavery was officially abolished in
1873 but actually wasn't even officially
abolished in 1873 that was only slavery
in the Confederacy it didn't actually
get fallin abolished for the entire
country until 1875 which is again not
something that we were taught so while I
don't ever think that you can take one
thing that has worked in one country and
you know go one to one in another
country I do think that you can learn
from other countries successes and
failures as well and are you hopeful
that America will history of oppression
so it has things have the interesting
thing so a couple of things that
happened in the United States past three
years it was very difficult to finish
this book because I started it in the
Obama administration when people really
were so after the Charleston massacre
people were taking down the Confederate
flag people were beginning to deal with
that and Donald Trump was a backlash I
mean the main reason why Donald Trump
was elected
is that there is a sizable group of
Americans who did not want a black
family in the White House as the slogan
went and the interesting thing I think
was my family was perfect
they really were we have not had and the
whole family from the grandmother to to
the kids as one of my daughters said at
the time so I can't imagine anything
worse than being a teenager in the White
House but to be the first African
American teenagers in the White House it
was been awful
and they were perfect so you know that
was a lie to every bit of racist
ideology that somehow says that black
people can't you know achieve on either
the measure of you know achievement
virtue or anything else so we had a
backlash at the same time lots of people
have begun to say well that was the
first reconstruction and now we're in
the second period of backlash again this
period of reconstruction that was not
only did people not know about it people
the white supremacist actually just lied
about it was ten years space between the
end of the civil war where African
Americans newly freed slaves slaves were
given all kinds of civil rights were
protected where the federal government
actually fought the Klan where you had
black senators from Mississippi no and
it was all rolled back so we're in a
period of a rollback but we're also in a
period of a lot of consciousness about
the history I you know I'm
I'm hopeful not because I know what the
future is going to be but because I
think we have a moral obligation to be
hopeful because if we're not we won't
make any kind of progress
so I'm hopeful out of obligation not
because I have a clue about what the
future is going to bring we're facing a
whole lot of danger for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas her III
TV
you